Trying to read a lot of material during a
busy day can be tough, especially if the material
is not in your first language.
Let’s take a look at a few different techniques
to help you read more but spend less time
doing it.
You don’t always have to read articles or
books to improve your reading skills.
It can be as simple as reading the menu, billboards,
street signs or just reading anything you
see in English every day.
If you do enjoy reading, set aside a few minutes
a day to read a book.
Like anything in life, practice will make
you a better reader.
Just because you're reading in English, it
doesn’t mean you have to read things you
have no interest in.
In fact, reading about something you’re
interested in can speed up your reading and
understanding of the text, especially as you
may already know a lot about it.
Think about what you like reading in your
own language.
For example, do you support a football club?
You could read their latest match report.
Do you like to know what the Kardashians are
up to?
You could read about the latest episode.
Whatever it is you read, thinking a little
about it or having knowledge of the content
can help you greatly.
Sometimes you might not have time to read
everything but you may need to find specific
information from the text you're reading.
For example, let’s say you're thinking of
going on holiday to Sydney and you want to
find out about the weather several months
ahead.
Using your favourite search engine to look
for a travel page, scan for the keyword, and
here it will be ‘climate’ or ‘weather’.
Get to the right section and find the information
you need.
Make a mental note, or if you're reading a
paper, highlight the area for later.